vous vous jouiez cet après midi dont tu
dis pas ce que vous avez vraiment donné
une représentation pour les finalistes
le jury lui malheureusement n'a pas pu
vous suivre parce que le jury était lui
aussi obligé de travailler dans un autre
domaine
eh bien il fallait corriger les copies
sacré travail vous rappelle donc y avait
cent soixante-huit finalistes et ce jury
a planché entre guillemets il a fallu
donc corrigé li a passé des heures je
vous dis en confidence on connaît les
résultats là que depuis quelques
instants
il y avait même des ex-aequo fallait
lire très précisément la dictée c'est
vrai était pleine de pièges
il y avait les juniors les seniors
amateurs les seniors professionnels
qu'il fallait corriger
alors alors alors maintenant nous aussi
oui il faut qu'on connaisse c'est dicter
comment devrait-on écrire tous ces mots
que bernard pivot nous dictait vous
savez comme au théâtre on change de
décor jour de lieux on y va et
maintenant on va dans la salle de classe
avec d'un pivot pour le corriger avec le
dire
soyez les bienvenus dans cette salle de
classe
recréée par michel millecamps avec vous
voyez tous les attributs de la salle de
classe de notre enfance ans est ouvert
de la mienne avec donc deux des lauréats
des prix littéraires erik orsenna et
alexandre jardin
erik orsenna combien douzaine de fautes
à peu près ce qui est bien c'est bel et
bien oui c'est bien non c'est bien c'est
bien non non non eh bien non c'est très
bien parce que vous savez il y avait
beaucoup de buts 20 fautes
c'est fréquent à la school avait trouvé
difficile oui oui ben donc vous voyez
c'est assez bien voulait prendre le
micro ce serait gentil
voilà simplement j'ai regardé votre
copine vous fait beaucoup de fautes
d'inattention vous est excellent dans
les pièges mais alors là où il n'y a pas
de piège vous tombé dedans c'est curieux
mais ça c'est votre humour c'est
l'humour d'orsenna vous pourrez
retrouver c'est une bourde dans son
roman
l'exposition julia quant à vous alors
alexandre jardin il a fait il a fait
n'importe quoi le lien
il a vraiment écrit n'importe quoi n'est
ce pas une micro sinon pas n'importe
quoi puisque j'ai essayé de de
substituer aux mots que vous nous dites
y ait des mots différents qui conservait
la qui conservait la même sonorité
alexandre jardin est un peu
alors il est tout à fait vrai qu'il faut
avoir une bonne orthographe mais on peut
être un très grand écrivain et avoir une
très mauvaise orthographe je devrais pas
le dire mais c'est vrai on connaît de
très grands écrivains qui écrivent mal
ne connaissent pas les règles de
grammaire mais que beaucoup de talent ça
doit être un peu le cas je pense
d'alexandre jardin
il doit être un peu brouillé avec
l'orthographe voilà et puis le jury le
jury national qui va m'aider dans le
corrigé de la dictée car en effet
maintenant c'est l'heure de ce fameux
corriger et j'avais demandé donc via le
tableau noir et on va tourner au fur et
à mesure et vous verrez d'ailleurs on
verra au fur et à mesure d'ailleurs la
proportion de fautes que vous avez
commises et c'est ibm qui nous en fera
le compte rendu
alors voici donc la longue ballade de
démo est bien évidemment la balade
c'était le voyage
je dois dire que le c'était un piège les
pièges de sang sont toujours
intéressants dans une dictée ç'aurait pu
être une ode et là on a écrit balade
avec deux ailes mais le sens était
presque très précis on parlait des
globe-trotters les mots voyage et c'est
donc le synthé précis mais à
l'instigation du jury j'ai ajouté l'ong
pour qu'il n'y ait vraiment pas
d'ambiguïté donc c'est la longue ballade
des mots combien de gens ont fait la
faute
est-ce que j'ai le résultat voilà
quatorze pour cent ont fait la faute à
balad
les mots ont la bougeotte c'est go2 t e
et bm va nous dire combien de personnes
ont fait la faute à la bougeotte 23% ont
fait une faute ce qui est ce qui est pas
mal
seul ou groupés ils forcent les
frontières passe par dessus les vallons
alors par dessus qu'est ce qui peut
jean-marie ego c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à ne pas mettre de trait
d'union a par dessus
oui il faut prenez les micro interne on
ne l'entendra pas on a tendance à être
pas mais de trait d'union parce que
peut-être à en dessus ou en dessous on
n'en met pas et on peut faire la
confusion
mais là par dessus est une locution près
positive qui demande le trait d'union
combien de fautifs pour par-dessus
intéressant de le savoir
par-dessus combien de fautifs qu'on ne
le sera pas les 26 s'il vous plaît les
vallons bon je passe les vallons les
vallées v les puits alors les puis
évidemment s'agissait pas des pubs et 8
aces s'il s'agissait des puits comme le
puy de dôme le cantal
donc ça s'écrit pays y est 13% ont fait
une faute si mich scmt dans nos
fourre-tout four toubab soleil ce sont
des ce sont des d'aider chaque des sacs
ou orange un peu tout voilà biechlin
seulement vous avez une définition plus
précise du fourre tout vous avez
certainement et pour tous oui tout le
monde a des pour tout gérer simplement
que vont il ne fallait pas mettre de s à
four parce que ça vient du verbe forêt
et que tout est un adverbe est restée
invariable
alors continuons avec dans le fourre
tout voyage avec nos nippes et noah
futur bâle et nip
c'est un mot familier ce sont des
vêtements un peu usagé et noah futur qui
est un mot peut-être un peu plus rare
avec un accent circonflexe sur le u
les happy few bien ce sont des objets
que l'on met sur soi qui sont non pas
beaucoup de valeur c'est des objets un
peu de parures facile voudrait-on les
empêcher de s'envoler tous azimuts tous
azimuts
on pourrait demander la relaxe de dire
quels pièges de tous azimuts tous
azimuts ne prend pas contrairement à ce
que beaucoup de gens écrit 20 h
ils vont pas comprendre qu'il faut pas
confondre avec zénith ou avec bismuth et
c'est un mot qui vient de l'arabe qui se
prononce je crois en arabe mais là on
prenne corrigé à salt et qui veut dire
chemin tout simplement que cela se
révèlerait inopérant révèlerait il faut
effectivement 2 accent aigu
car les mots sont cachés dans notre
bouche là ça n'avait aucune défini
aucune difficulté embusqué derrière nos
connaught c'est un très joli mot de la
langue française
ce sont les laits dans notre lui est où
nos amis d'al on ne prononce plus depuis
plusieurs années le géant nous prononcer
autrefois mais on ne le prononce plus
avec des amygdales
ce qu'il ya une statistique sur abidal
je ne crois pas sitôt arrivé à montréal
à canberra bombe a coûté la vie
d'avancer des noms propres mais qu'ils
sont universellement connu il ne fallait
pas certains ont fait la faute à
canberra d'ailleurs 31% ont fait une
faute à canberra et ont mis évidemment m
devant le bébé très souvent vous en
oubliez on omis que et kinshasa 18 % ont
fait une faute en revanche montréal il
n'y a pas eu de faute
à peine avons nous les uns ou les autres
desserrer les lièvres les lèvres pardon
et serré les lèvres bon bah ça se
présentait pas peut-être une grosse
difficulté que les mots pressé de
s'égailler dans la nature de s'égailler
j'ai bien je n'ai pas dit s'égayer mais
ces gars y est c'est à dire se disperser
s'éparpiller 14% ont fait la faute à
s'égailler s'échappe comme des
étourneaux
alors les étourneaux sont des petits
oiseaux très familier ils ont un
synonyme ce sont les sansonnet j'ai
hésité entre sansonnet et étourneaux
paix juste a dit étourneaux parce qu'il
vous est plus familier et puis on ne vit
pas de la roupie d'étourneaux les mots
sont d'infatigables blog trotteur alors
là les globe-trotters effectivement il
faut un ace c'est un mot franglais mais
qui est entré depuis longtemps dans la
langue française et j'ai prononcé
globe-trotter globe-trotter parce que
les deux prononciation se disent ils se
jouent défaut il est décent sur les mots
sont libres comme l'air et la sarre
était la dictée pour les juniors et je
vous signale que deux juniors on fait
zéro faute
mais de tout temps
ben oui c'était au heat et qu'il veut
faire une remarque jean pierre colignon
très rapidement les âges a tranché en
faveur du singulier au sens de l'anah
portes qu'à l'époque on aurait pu
adopter un pluriel mais l usage a
tranché pour le singulier on le respecte
mais de tout temps les mots se sont
battus se sont battus la spécialiste
micheline seulement du participe passé
accidentellement pronominale se sont
battus ils s'accordent donc d'anticiper
ses prouesses particularité ici c'est
qui en fait ils adoptent une forme
curieusement essentiellement pronominale
parce que le seuil n'est pas analysable
dans ce cas là au nominal subjectif
voilà que deux verbes que deux verbes et
d'adjectifs frappées d'obsolescence
l'obsolescence et l étape quelque chose
qui devient un peu caduque y passe de
mode frappées d'obsolescence se sont
retirés du trafic que de nomades taupe
et se sont ressemblés alors et chine
seulement allons-y alors se sont
ressemblés donc ressembler concurrence
de ressembler et nuit sont des
participes passés nuit on verra plus
tard qu'ils sont toujours un variable
est en revanche les trois autres
s'accordait alors il ya douze verbes
pronominaux dont le participe passé est
invariable ressembler les nuits en
faisait partie
donc il ne fallait pas accorder
ressembler 10 % d'erreurs concurrence et
donc la concurrence s accordent de même
qu'à propos de capot ce trophée exclus
qui vont suivre ils font partie de la
même catégorie
ce sont des verbe transitif employés pro
nominalement ici apostrophé qui me colle
vraiment à la peau après se refait et
ios c'est la même voilà c'est la même
règle exclut également c'est la même
réduit alors variable invariable
puisqu'il est quelque chose
ensemble et je veux dire que tous nos
instituteurs nous ont appris qu'il
fallait chercher le complément d'objet
direct voilà moi c'est ce que je fais
voilà alors est-ce que ça répond à quoi
ou à qui ou pas après ressembler nuit ya
pas de réponse
voilà ce sont donc des verbe transitif
indirects voilà moi les voies urinaires
je vais toujours le raisonnement jeudi
on a un peu ce trophée qui alors on
apprend que ce trophée des gens donc
c'est complément direct donc ça
s'accordent nuit on peut pas dire nuit
quelqu'un ont nui à quelqu un complément
et direct c'est un variable
si vous rêvez d'un jeune instituteur
voit la nuit exclut donc exclu quelqu'un
c'est complément d'objet direct
es que de substantifs caduque et
prétentieux de petits maîtres alors de
petits m bien entendu pour moi ça n'a
fait quelques-uns ont contesté moi je
pense qu'il faut mettre le pluriel parce
que fatalement c'est l'ensemble des
substantifs prononcé par l'ensemble des
petits maîtres si vous mettiez par
exemple que de substantifs qu'as-tu
caduque et prétentieux de deux
secrétaires ou de patrons bien vous
mettriez automatiquement le pluriel se
sont laissé supplanter c'est encore un
piège michine seulement mais n'enlevez
pas il veut garder votre micro comme ça
des micros se sont laissé supplanter là
il faut savoir qui fait l'action de
supplanter si c'est le sujet laisser sa
corde si ce n'est pas le sujet l'essai
reste invariable bon ici ce sont les
mots succulent qui supplante ce n'est
pas ce ne sont pas les substantifs donc
laissé reste invariable se sont laissé
supplanter par les mots succulent des
rastaquouère alors un rastaquouère c'est
le brésilien d'offenbach c'est à dire
c'est autrefois c'est un étranger aux
allures voyante qui affiche déjà un peu
dé manière désinvolte et très trop
voyantes
alors maintenant un rastaquouère c'est
plutôt un mot péjoratif qui désigne à
l'étranger mais j'ai enlevé le côté
péjoratif de l'étranger en parlant des
mots succulent des rastaquouère je
trouve d'ailleurs ce tableau assez
difficile à écrire et qui est un très
joli mot d'un française si on l'emploie
bien le vocabulaire détonnant et
drolatique je dis bien en même temps le
vocabulaire étonnant et drolatique qui
est ce qu il veut parler de ça
jean pierre colignon voici les deux
plaidé le dossier puisque certains pour
tester les 2 n à d'étonnants bien sûr
nous sommes sous la révolution puisque
l'on parle plus tard de sans culotte
mais en fait il s'agit là de l'arrivée
d'un vocabulaire un peu populaire voire
trivial qui vient s'affronter au langage
précieux de la cour donc le sens
principal qu'on devait affecter à ce mot
était celui de insolite donc d'étonnant
avec deux n
alors je vais expliquer alors d'
étonnant détonnant avec un soleil ça
veut dire qui est susceptible d'exploser
on parle un case d'étonnant un mélange
détonnant détonnant avec deux n sa
signification ça veut dire sortir du ton
général sortir quelqu'un qui n'est plus
dans l'harmonie de l'époque
il est évident que dans la mesure où
après il y as drolatique
cela veut dire que il ya un an il y
avait une confusion de sens il y avait
je jouais là dessus cela veut dire que
si cet étonnant ça explose de tous les
côtés ce n'est pas drôle atik donc
d'étonnant ça veut dire que c'est un il
employer un vocabulaire qui n'était plus
celui de l'ancien régime qui n'est plus
en harmonie avec le le passé et qui est
donc d'étonnant et drolatique parce que
c'est un ce serait un langage inventif
alors le voeu kabila détonnant et
drolatique descend cunault remercie vous
n'avez pas le vivre des sans-culottes
alors tard les joies savoir combien on
fait faute détonnant 25 % seulement ont
fait la faute à d'étonnants et je
signale d'ailleurs qu'il y a un champion
amateur qui a fait zéro faute et qui a
donc fait pas de faute à d'étonnants
alors gros net alors drolatique
drolatique n'a pas d'accent circonflexe
sur le haut des sans-culottes alors les
sens qu a eu l'heur de régénérer leur
alors que leur qui veut jean pierre
colignon
oui on trouve donc l'élément qui figure
dans bonheur est dans mahler ce vient du
latin augure y sommes il faut donc bien
sûr l'écrire heures-20 pas heures comme
heures d'horloge ni heures qui découlent
de heurter de régénérer
substantiellement ben c'est un mot un
peu l'eau mais pas tellement compliqué
de la langue d esbroufe d'hier les
esbroufes c'est une manière un petit peu
en ferronnerie à peu chic et un petit
peu comme ça là esbroufe 12% seulement
fait une faute mais attention
these ce beauf d'hier au malang d'accent
circonflexe sur le haut sont devenus
alors eu le rss bof et féminin prosaïsme
rabâcher d'aujourd'hui que deux fois
t'es tu retrouvé ma douce peyronnel une
peyronnel c'est une autre fois une jeune
fille très bavarde et un petit peu sauté
la langue au fond est aussi évidemment
très bavarde et parfois un peu seul
ballotté jean-marie ego ballotté de zèle
de thé est ce que beaucoup ont fait la
faute
je sais pas mais rooney et aux
prochaines élections dernière il
faudrait demander à antenne 2 et aux
autres chaînes aussi de bien m'être
ballottage avec deux t sur l'écran car
il ya souvent qu'un paix au gré des
modes imprévisible maintenant tout va
plus vite et les mots eux aussi se sont
mises au prêt-à-porter
il ya deux traits d'union va c'est pas
difficile au clonage
alors le clonage c'est la reproduction
d'un individu que ce soit un animal un
homme ou une plante par
en prenant une seule cellule c'est un
mot scientifique nouveau et alors là le
mot qui je pense va faire fureur dans
les jours qui viennent c'est la pop up à
la pop up spontanée nous faisons tous
des apocope sans le savoir
c'est bien quand on dit télé pour
télévision ont fait une apocope quand on
dessinait pour cinéma quand on dit à
poste pour apostrophe c'est une apocope
c'est à dire celle élisions de la
dernière ou des dernières syllabes d'un
mot et il y a des impôts couples
célèbres comme par exemple le petit déj
aujourd'hui les les adolescents parlent
ou bien le dans le quotidien l'équipe on
parle des perfs pour les performances
des athlètes et une apocope célèbre
c'est celle qui a lancé philippe aubert
avec steph de mosnac ça c'est une double
apocope quand on dit un bus pour
l'autobus
là ce n'est plus une apocope maintenant
la selle c'est une aphérèse voilà c'est
une affaire elle s'y est monsieur 7000
aphérèse donc on vit quand on dit alarmé
pitaine pour capitaine c'est une
aphérèse mais le plan pour l'emploi
beaucoup moins tandis que les impôts
clubs sont à la mode
alors voilà je pose tu causes il cause
la plus belle cause c'est la langue là
il n'y avait plus de il n'y avait plus
de difficultés
voilà un commentaire et un corset
n'assure est-ce que vous connaissiez le
sens du mot apocope à peu près un peu
comme lui mais je vois que j'ai
incroyablement besoin de dictionnaire
vive robert vitré je signale aux
téléspectateurs que le corrigé de la
dictée avec le pourcentage des fautes
selon ibm
vous retrouverez tout cela sur le
minitel 36 15
ap hausse à partir de 20 heures
seulement un pas deux pas avancé par là
vous n'aurez pas avant 20 heures
d'affiliée l'émission jusqu'au bout pour
attiser des questions subsidiaires
peut-être non dites moi vous avez créé
une situation explosive avec votre mode
étonnant il y avait de la contestation
c'est bien qu'on puisse contester c'est
bien plus contesté à un mois
d'ailleurs je dois dire cette dame qui
est pour détonnant avec avec un seul n l
est
son attitude ici et détonante avec deux
n
voilà mais si elle vient mais si elle
vient chez moi me mettre une bombe
et bien cette dame elle sera détonnant
avec un soleil voilà on en n'est
peut-être pas là alors évidemment on ne
faisait que poser la blouse bernard
parce que sérieusement commencer à
willamette la phalange la face et veut
dire cadeau cadeaux bons cadeaux voilà
des cadeaux il faut qu'ils arrivent des
livres bien sûr délivre une sorte de
gâteau de cadeaux alors c'est le le
gâteau le gâteau de cadeaux et de livres
de michel millecamps et là oui bien
entendu ce sont des récompenses avec
l'encyclopaedia universalis
l'encyclopédie gerald achète
l'encyclopédie des connaissances d'ozon
fayat si le dictionnaire encyclopédique
de quille mais c'est tout cela il ya
grand quiz illustré de la foule grand
robert langue française univers des
formes de gallimard le littré l'angle de
la langue française de chez britannique
à l'histoire la population française des
pubs pour ses ouvrages formidable
récompenseront les lauréats à laure
donnât il faut bien rappeler qu'il ya
trois catégories de champion les juniors
les seniors amateurs et les seniors
professionnels et qu'il y aura donc
trois champions dans des classes
différentes
la france les pays francophones les pays
étrangers non francophones
alors on va commencer par la france et
pour cela j'appelle à nouveau
christophe malavoy
donc on va commencer par citer les
champions de france et le junior juniors
christophe c'est là le champion junior
alors j'appelle j'ai l'honneur d'appeler
patrice bula de clermont ferrand mois
voilà il faut ajouter quelque chose pour
peugeot judas écoutez bien j'ajoute
qu'il a fait zéro faute
patrice patrice bula zéro faute
il a été départagé parce qu'une autre
candidate a fait zéro faute et je vais
lui demander de venir ici c'est caroline
mathieu de nice
[Applaudissements]
alors zéro faute c'est quand même un
exploit oui c'est à dire que je me suis
beaucoup entraîné
le petit larousse c'est lui le
dictionnaire des difficultés de langue
française j'ai pris beaucoup de notes et
j'essaie d'apprendre tout ça donc ça m'a
permis de douter sur un seul mot
seulement
oui vous êtes étudiant en quoi oui je
suis actuellement en classe de terminale
c est vous êtes évidemment un train un
crack en français c'est à dire qu'un
terminal il n'y a plus de français ah
oui c'est vrai c'est la philo vrai c'est
vrai j'oubliais publiait alors caroline
mathieu de nice vous avez fait aussi
zéro faute et vous avez été départagé
avec les pièges de micheline seulement
aux questions subsidiaires et vous avez
fait une foule une ou deux fautes de
plus que patrice bula n'êtes pas trop
déçu enfin vous êtes quand même seconde
je suis content que content d'être 2e
surtout que le prix le deuxième prime
plaisait plus que le premier
avez vous hésité sur un mot oui j'ai
hésité sur la première phrase c'est
tellement plus du tout d'ailleurs le mot
roth jeu du jeune ont la bougeotte
bonjour voila moi c'était l'accent sur
un futur et vous l'avez mis bravo bravo
les applaudirons faut aller vers nous
l'a donnée vers nous on va maintenant
appeler le champion senior amateur
le champion amateur donc j'ai l'honneur
d'appeler michel de romanovs le
fontainebleau
michèle torr roma n'a pas fait et michel
bouchez toromanof a fait une seule faute
une seule faute et il a été voulez vous
tournez départager aussi de parce que
monsieur henri dubost de versailles
n'avaient fait qu'une photo si vous
l'avez emporté il à votre faute
c'est étonnant j'ai essayé de détonner
mais j'ai pas plus est-ce que vous avez
tenant et un soleil est-ce que vous
aussi vous vous êtes entraînés oui à
l'époque je suis retraité mais de quel
point j'étais ancien ingénieur des mines
ingénieur au jeu au gaz de france très
bien bravo
venez nous rejoindre plutôt romanov
venez nous rejoindre
maintenant nous allons appeler le
champion senior professionnels alors
j'ai l'honneur d'appeler bernard où la
masse et montpellier ou assemat ces
messieurs bernard masset non mais celle
de montpellier
et après lui aussi 0 faute c'est un zéro
faute
monsieur me fait évidemment vous vous
n'avez pas d'étonner 1
vous l'avez trouvé facile cette dictée
j'ai hésité
autant que la personne qui tout à
l'heure ces plaintes a contesté je
trouvais que les deux pouvaient aussi
bien aller l'un que l'autre
mais si vous me connaissez alors évident
que il y avait un piège de sens c'est
évident mais si on me connaît et après
drolatique drolatique après détonnant on
peut penser que j'ai choisi plus
l'humour plutôt que la violence j'ai
pensé également que les sans culottes et
est détonnant par leur langage surtout
voilà
eh bien vous avez fait le bon
raisonnement alors connais monsieur
merci on va on va se livrer dans une
petite remise de prix à christophe mas
en sachant que ce ne sont pas les prix
définitifs
vous êtes d'accord ça ne soit pas allée
prélat alors on va donner d'abord les
certificats peut-être christophe soulez
su remettre les certificats voilà
certificat pour les champions donc 1988
pour la catégorie france et puis des
stylos parce que il faut écrire je vous
remets à twitter en passant devant vous
quand même voilà bon bah on va aller
peut-être un peu plus vite la passe plus
parce que le temps presse il devrait le
remercier au passage de la je vais faire
comme aux chiffres et les lettres ya
toujours une orange et là de
personnalités important de voir monsieur
brun buisson leiter l'antenne de
monsieur creux grobet grébert pardon le
directeur des relations de fr3 monsieur
roland chabot
je remercie et cetera il ya aussi
monsieur arzika tâche et alliances
françaises le minadt darbon alors je
remercie d'ailleurs spécialement bien
darmon elle est là de le crédit agricole
parce que sans le mécénat du crédit
agricole ces championnats ne pourrait
pas exister
et puis
et puis jean pierre géhanne cas de
france télécom mais michel visbecq de
tms qui assure la bonne santé tous les
candidats et maintenant nous passons en
fait d'abord demandé à nos cordiales à
nos champions france d'aller prendre
leur place dans la classe voilà c'est
lui on va remercie beaucoup christophe
malavoy d'être venus accueillir hu joue
demain merci christophe maintenant et on
va parler maintenant nous allons passer
à la catégorie aux pays francophones et
j'appelle pour cela manu dibango manu
dibango va remettre donc avec le
monsieur à musiciens vous êtes d'origine
on vous connaît dans le monde entier
maintenant c'est des choses qui arrivent
bowman ne vous êtes d'accord vous allez
nous donner maintenant à voile avec
votre micro le nom du champion junior
pour les pays francophones
alors il s'appelle jean christian pleo
il est du québec jean christian klien
aut
et
[Musique]
et il le fait qu'une demi faute et en
vérité en vérité ici monsieur en vérité
ils auraient dû faire un zéro faute qui
a ou a qui touche à ça il a simplement
oublié l'accent sur le à parce que bien
entendu il le sait mais voilà c'est une
faute d'étourderie autrement vous auriez
fait zéro faute québécois donc c'est un
québécois qui a battu les belges les
suisses vraiment toute la francophonie
vous êtes vraiment très fort en si vous
êtes étudiant
oui en littérature française d'ailleurs
un passionné de grammaire passionné non
je m'intéresse à évidemment mais bravo
on l'applaudît
mais des nouveaux chemins de la pression
ne rejoint et maintenant on va appeler
le champion senior amateur toujours pour
les pays francophones dans cette fois ci
elle vient de suisse il s'agit de madame
ou mademoiselle jeanne instead claire
bur burnand burnand janis est leur
bureau note il vient de suisse
il s'assied à l'école et les
francophones suisse qu'ils avaient
rejoint dès l'année 1986 c'est une
suissesse et elle n'a commis que deux
fautes et demi qu'elle
quel est votre profession je suis femme
au foyer j'ai élevé mes enfants
maintenant j'ai un petit peu de
tranquillité à la maison et j'ai depuis
la demi-finale j'ai révisé sa
tranquillité ou l'employé a regardé les
dictionnaires les grammaires ces trois
dernières semaines
honnêtement oui bravo bravo mais là vous
venez nous allons maintenant appeler le
champion senior professionnels nous
restons toujours en suisse avec francis
close
oui petite culotte
oh là là et grossistes et les supporters
alors en substance attentiste suisse et
qui n'a commis qu'une faute une seule
faute ou à d'étonnants à vous êtes des
violences en suisse oui c'est notre
réputation bien elle a quel est votre
profession vous des professionnels
je suis instituteur j'aimerais
d'ailleurs signalait la présence d'une
grande partie de ma classe qui m'a coupé
la
parce qu'il savait que vous alliez
gagner d'abobo voilà m on va remettre
les prix même chose les certificats de
mérite à champions champions 1988 pour
les pays francophones
et puis et puis des stylos on va vous de
travailler un peu je fais travailler
vous tenez un hommage à monsieur stylo
celle au parterre et puis maintenant on
va passer bien à la troisième catégorie
bernard et la catégorie aux pays
étrangers non francophones et pour cela
j'appelle le philippe jeantot votre
place quand la classe
alors que luc chanteau le navigateur
tout le monde connaît on va à philippe
je vous demande et de citer d'appeler
maintenant
le champion junior pour les pays
étrangers non francophones c'est très
difficile exercice difficile on a une
tâche difficile puisque c'est me cac me
narcotiques polonais
un telle est né
quatre sets et demi seulement quatre
fonds et demi imaginez la performance
bravo
vous êtes étudiant à part celui à
craquer me suis dit c est vous êtes vous
fait du français depuis combien d'années
et vous avez trouvé le cette dictée
facile difficile indique t elle même
était bien difficile
je pense que la partie après partie
celle pour les juniors était plutôt
facile quand même bien bravoure
l'applaudît nous allons maintenant
appeler le champion senior amateur
philippe il s'agit donc d'un américain
fédéric weinling les états unis un
américain
monsieur frédéric berling qui a commis
sur l'ensemble de la dictée neuf fautes
seulement sais pas mais je suivais glynn
quel est votre profession je suis
ingénieur électronicien physicien dans
quelles villes les états unis et vous
la langue française est une langue qui
vous est familier depuis combien
d'années
eh bien depuis l'âge de 5 ans pendant
les cinq premières années de ma vie je
parlais d'autres langues plusieurs
d'entre elles et à partir de l'âge de 5
ans j'ai étudié le français à l'école
primaire en belgique
eh bien merci monsieur d'illustrer avec
tant de brio notre langue
merci beaucoup et maintenant et
maintenant nous allons appeler le
champion senior professionnels c'est un
candidat qui vient de singapour
alors nos ring à eau c'est une candidate
et
alors laurine au de singapour est certes
une professionnelle va nous dire sa
profession mais elle n'a commis que
trois fautes
quel est votre profession enseignante et
vous enseigner le français
il avait appris le français très tôt à
19 ans mais c'est formidable et vous
avez beaucoup d'élèves à singapour qui
apprennent le français
environ 1000 milles mais c'est
formidable donc le français est une
langue qui marche bien actuellement à
singapour
oui oui très bien et bien bravo qu'un
jour on est très content pour à la fois
pour saya pour que ça pète on dit merci
et les ados de renaître les prix voit la
même chose je suis dit ou faire
travailler peut dire qu'on a été très
très surpris de la grande grande
participation des singapouriens il y
avait 5000 participants 5000 personnes
qui se sont présentées dont classé
championnat bravo félicitations d'un art
on va demander au sila donc nous
champions d'aller même chose rejoindre
la classe vont donc maintenant les neuf
champions 1988 puis à des personnalités
que nous allons appeler voilà nous
allons appeler parce que maintenant vous
allez recevoir vos gros cadeau
évidemment alors je vais appeler
monsieur est ce que là c'était un avant
goût on est bien d'accord ce qu'on a
donné c'était un avant goût donc
maintenant eh bien maintenant il va
falloir retenir est le monsieur rené
l'apôtre président directeur général du
thé à monsieur jean claude noël le
directeur général de hilton
international et monsieur bruno favier
directeur de la communication de ibm si
vous voulez monter rapidement s'il vous
plaît
voilà alors laissons les prix pour les
premiers alors c'est un voyage ce sont
des voyages pour 2 personnes pour chacun
des neuf des neuf candidats lauréats
lauréat n'est ce pas que la compagnie
directeur une de leur offrir à jakarta à
paris et à singapour singapour enfin
bravo
alors messieurs les hôtels hilton ils
vont loger dans les hôtels hilton
bien entendu ce sont des voyages qui
vont venir en accompagnement avec ut à
signer à singapour ou à paris pour ceux
qui viennent de ces de ces pays éloignés
et monsieur fabié ce sont des machines à
écrire électronique avec un dictionnaire
de 150 mille mots merci à tous alors
donnez moi tout ça je leur corps leur
donnerait en votre honneur nous font la
distribution après l'émission
voilà merci et puis un invité il y en a
vite et qui hélas est ce que il est là
ou pas non il n'a pas l'air d'être là
c'est vraiment il est décidément c'est
un mauvais élève
c'est un mauvais dont j'attendais son
nom de dieu mais je ne vois pas venir
[Rires]
j'ai l'impression que vous avez des
toujours mauvais en orthographe
c'est tout à fait normal mais pourquoi y
at-il un trait d'union entre 100 et
antonio parce que lorsque j'ai choisi un
pseudonyme je voulais prendre un
pseudonyme inna américain j'ai pris une
carte des états unis j'ai mis le doigt
dessus et je suis tombé sur san antonio
c'était gagné
et alors j'ai écrit san antonio et comme
je n'avais pas le temps de mémoriser
j'ai mis un trait d'union et maintenant
je devrais je tiens à ce trait d'union
comme à la prunelle de mes yeux
et quand un imprimeur mais pas montré
d'une offre une crise bien vous faites
beaucoup de fautes dans vos manuscrits
énormément à propos de la dictée gelé
j'ai réussi à la faire alors j'ai une
bonne nouvelle à vous non à vous
annoncer
insolent à futur très bien bravo le seul
que j'ai orthographe et convenablement
dana on a une petite avec manu dibango
manu dibango
elle va mettre aux musiques de phrases
de france elle a dicté de l'unité rasé
pendant un jeu demandé aux aux candidats
des pays acp les italie et pays
francophones des pays étrangers retenus
deux phrases il y en a eu que je vais
chanter tout seul est une que vous allez
chanter avec moi si vous voulez bien
[Musique]
e
et
je cause du cause il causait la plus
belle le coz
c'est là l'un des jeux cause tu causes
il cause la plus belle le coz c'est la
langue est oui alors la plus belle cause
oui encore une fois je cause du cause
ils causent bobo banque la plus belle
cause c'est la langue merci mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs je demande aux
filles du candidat des pays étrangers de
monter tout cela sur la sur l'estrade à
s'y coller et les candidats des pays
étrangers francophones et non
francophones ainsi que les candidats des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
alesi venez vite nous sommes pressés
venez vite
oui voilà maintenant terminée cette
émission dans la fête la bonne humeur
dans une sorte de grande convivialité de
la langue française
vous avez si merveilleusement défendu et
je hais je rappelle je rappelle que les
téléspectateurs carrière de batteur
vous pourrez voir sur antys 15 codes
apos le le les corriger l origine de la
liga avec tous les résultats de cette
journée bravo à vous donner donner tous
vous avez là tous les finalistes
monsieur roger gauche de lire française
qui a tant fait pour tous ces candidats
étrangers
voilà
[Musique]
et
sur l'a7 où découvrir au fur et à mesure
les 168 finalistes je vous rappelle
qu'il y avait là-bas des finalistes qui
venait du monde entier voilà nous sommes
obligés maintenant bernard de nous
quitter c'est fini pour les championnats
du monde d'orthographe de l'ong
française 1988 c'est dire bien sûr que
nous vous donnons rendez vous à l'année
prochaine pour 1989 où nous retrouvons
neuf autres champions bernat avoue
peut-être le moule de fans non mais
écoutez moi je suis très contente c'est
bien à la rue ont reçu leur milieu de
tous et de tous ces grands amoureux de
la langue française celle en présentant
de batman
alors vous allez avoir un collier de
merci à tous merci nous avons su vite
merci d'un cheval au revoir
[Musique]
que
le
très cher bernard pivot si vous doutez
encore de votre popularité dans les
tailles de voir d'autres maires et aux
antipodes et bien à douter plus est avec
affection que l'archipel des marquises
vous encore lierre que celui des tuamotu
vous en collier également combien
avez-vous fait faute que je vous fais
trop jeune je ne 4
peut-être je me voyais pas aller au delà
aussi un comble quand les australes les
cinq archipels les gambier et les îles
sous le vent larosace de l'amitié y
aller travailler
juniors et la brouille sa comédie mais
on me dit oui voilà c'était juste
l'asie passé à tous
les prochaines semaines
brigitte simon et ayem est formidable
[Musique]